try to convert 4 nights into a
percentage now if I gave you a nice easy
one
like say 3 over 10 and I said convert
that into a percentage it's gonna be 30
over hundreds so you multiply the top of
the bottom by a 10 and that's what makes
the denominator 100 so it's 30% now
that's fine easy numbers 5 if I gave you
tens or twenties or fives all those
kinds of things yeah it was an example
okay but for overnight is tricky there's
no whole number then you can multiply 9
by 2 get a hundred cuz think of the
multiples of 9 what animal is enough 9
18 27 36 45 54 63 72 81 90 99 99 and
then I had your name so we skip picky we
skipped over 100 so I can't just
multiply it by something easy right so
therefore you get your calculator so the
first thing you do actually minded me oh
okay now follow along with me if you go
4/9 if you're using the same calculator
as me sorry you don't get something very
useful it just tells you that yeah right
do you like it's not helpful so instead
you depress that as the SD button right
here between it okay no we're not
finished yet though this is a classic
example of where the calculator will
help you but it won't just spit out the
answer to you you've got to really think
okay so let's write this down this is
zero point 4 4 4 4
the fours go forever now I'm not gonna
do the dot you'll see why in a second
now what I've done is I've converted the
fraction into a decimal but I'm not done
yet
I want to convert it into a percentage
right so here's what I'll do I'm gonna
multiply by a hundred will not hundred
on its own I'm gonna multiply by a
hundred percent now here's why okay just
watch a hundred percent right what is
percent meaning up it means out of a
hundred right so what I'm really x is a
hundred over a hundred that's just one
so I'm not changing the number that's
really important okay it's just like
before when you were like okay he's a
fraction right well if you divide the
top and the bottom by the same thing
right divide by 2 divide by 2
it's still the same fraction it's still
uh-huh right so here I have to multiply
by 100 and divide by a hundred otherwise
I've actually mucked around with the
number and changed it okay sir I'm not
just multiply by a hundred that's
important I'll multiply by a hundred
percent okay now let's just think about
the number a hundred right that's gonna
move the decimal point how many times
how many times how do you know it
depends on how many zeros there are so I
count one two so I'm gonna move the
decimal point twice okay I'll do it here
see here there's my decimal point I'm
gonna be at once
and then I'm gonna move it twice it's
gonna end up there okay so here's what
I've got now forty four point four four
four four four four percent okay so
there's four the percentage but I could
write it just a little bit neater if you
remember from last year I believe we
know this thing called dot notation
right what does that mean
yes it's one color recurring decimal
sometimes you read as 44.4 repeater
repeater so it means it goes on and on
forever and that's the percentage okay
so let me just rehearse what did I do
okay number one you had to chuck in your
calculator but then it just gave you
four of a nine so you needed that button
right yes d okay that's what gave you
this okay but that's still not a
percentage it's just the decimal okay so
in order to change it from a decimal
into a percentage you can I multiply it
by a hundred percent okay by a hundred
percent right cuz you just multiply it
by 100 it's a whole new double right so
it's not the same the very last thing
that we did was we are we just tied it
up the way we wrote it okay so we had
that repeating there which is a better
way to write okay